China's president Xi Jinping has left
Moscow after two days of talks with
President Vladimir Putin the two leaders
issued a joint statement on Tuesday
calling for responsible dialogue to end
the war in Ukraine Putin says beijing's
proposals to end the conflict could be
used as the basis for a peace settlement
but that Kiev in the west do not appear
willing to resolve the situation
on Spring in journalist Julian
shapovalova from Moscow Julia how much
has President Putin actually got out of
this meeting
right
well I think he has to be pretty much
satisfied so many vitally important
issues have been addressed during the
meetings uh the Ukrainian conflict that
he said economy trade energy he praised
beijing's of course proposals for a
peaceful settlement of the crisis in
Ukraine has had the plan uh can be taken
as a basis for further agreements many
actually statements of the plan coincide
with Russia with Russia's approaches
Putin spoke about the growing trade ties
between the two countries a trade
turnover between Russia and China has
grown 116 in the course of 10 years
China is Russia's leading foreign trade
Partners we know and also the leaders
signed statements on deepening relations
of partnership and strategic cooperation
between the countries and a plan for the
development of key areas of Russian
Chinese economic cooperation until 2030
but is also important according to Mr
Putin uh the Russian Federation is ready
to switch to the U.N and trade with
other countries not just for Russia and
China Yuan payments will be in place for
Russia and the countries of Asia Africa
and Latin America according to Putin
Russia will increase Food Supplies to to
the Chinese market to the Chinese market
and there will be exports of meat grain
and other agricultural projects produce
regarding energy Russia remains a
strategic supply of oil natural gas
including LNG coal and electricity to
China the leaders discussed also the
construction of the power of Siberia to
gas pipeline which will pass through
Mongolia so plethora of issues which
will have massive future impact here
thank you very much indeed Julius from
Moscow we're going to bring in Katrina
you she's joining us now from Beijing
that there's been a lot of speculation
in the media following this two-day
meeting that essentially Russia needs
China more than China needs Russia what
has China gained from this meeting
we'll think China is sending the message
very clearly that despite the
consternation from the U.S and its
Western allies that China is continuing
to move forward and deepen its
relationship with Moscow Beijing
described this relationship as at its
highest level ever and basically this
relationship is here to stay despite
Russia moving forward with its invasion
of Ukraine now we had two documents
released uh joint statements released
from Xi Jinping and that maputan the
first was really looking at strategic
cooperation uh two countries say that
this is not a political or military
Alliance but they do seem to very much
share this world view that they are
against a us-led world order and to that
end they said that there would be more
Corporation through the blocks such as
SEO the Belton road infrastructure
project and uh through the brics
group as well but at the same time they
also criticized NATO and the orchestra
plan and then the second document was
about deepening economic cooperation
especially in the areas of Agriculture
and energy and in return Beijing gets
cheap oil and gas and it provides Russia
with a crucial economic Lifeline at a
time when the country's struggling with
sanctions from the West now I think
there's two things really mainly that
Beijing has achieved here and one is
that Xi Jinping has quite successfully I
think used this visit as a platform to
promote China's peace plan now Putin
said himself that they would discuss
this and and both sides during this
meeting said they would both wanted to
Mo to promote dialogue to prevent this
conflict in Ukraine from escalating now
it's clear that there was no concrete
outcome in terms of improving the
situation in Ukraine but what matters to
Beijing is that Xi Jinping at least
appeared to be a global statement
Statesman and Peacemaker during this
trip and the second uh thing that
Beijing has achieved well it really is
the Optics and the objects were that
this is a strong China supporting and
propping up a weak Russia and it does
really seem that Putin was the junior
partner here needing Xi Jinping now we
didn't see China crossing any red lines
offering for example Military Support uh
to Russia China so very much needs to
preserve the health of its relationship
especially economically with the EU but
at the same time we did see China
supporting Vladimir Putin throwing his
weight behind Vladimir Putin and needing
Russia to stay strong no matter how
Ukraine war ends and this is because
China desperately needs Russia not to
fail and Putin to remain in power for
this increasing confrontation that it
finds itself in it's increasing tensions
against the United States it needs
Moscow to be strong and and back there
in its Corner as that situation with the
U.S seems to be getting worse as Katrina
you bringing us up to date from Beijing
Katrina thank you very much indeed